for the actors i had to build a training
program for them their understanding of
radios of flying of being in an aircraft
being in confined spaces where it's hot
because you have responsibilities in
that f-18 you're not just going for a
ride you're actually there and you have
to learn certain things in case an
emergency happens
first if you're going to fly in the f-18
it is mandated by the navy that you go
through water survival training
there's various steps that the actors
must become proficient at don't be
afraid to do it like you mean it do it
like you're actually falling at 120
miles an hour they have to be able to do
it they can't do what they can't get in
the f-18
you're not likely to drown during this
training but it's significant physical
experience we had some that were they
were very challenged i did not know how
to swim so we went through intensive
swim training with some olympic coaches
i really enjoyed the swim training but
actually going to the testing facility
in miramar was a very different thing
the water survival training was heinous
had a little freak out
i was petrified i was like okay am i
gonna be able to do this we're about to
get dunked
there's all these different contraptions
and and things that like pull you
through the water and like drop you into
a tank
it's very intense you get blindfolded
strapped to a chair
water fills up they submerge you spin
you upside down you gotta get out
it's really been intense
[Music]